[Musique]
montrer
c'est pourquoi monsieur aubin brillant
s'il vous plaît ça quel étage qu'est ce
que voulez vous les aviez assez vous
êtes jolie famille ça fait des mois
qu'il a disparu il allait mal et sans
laisser d'adressé encore il l'est déjà
trois mois de loyer syndicat fait saisir
c'est mal
il en tirera pas tripette et ce à des
factures qui va les payer
après tout vous êtes de sa famille c'est
à vous de payer
il n'en est pas question ou alors
j'aurai à la ville qui se recoupent
[Musique]
je crois que mon oncle n'ait disparu
je crois qu'il est préférable que je
reprenne mon histoire depuis le début je
vivais à madagascar avec mon père qui
était planteur il est mort la nuit
dernière où j'ai tout liquider de
sextape autant pas le moment il se
rentrer en france
là bien sûr j'ai contacté les membres de
ma famille sont d'ailleurs que deux mais
deux oncles titus et aubin se
connaissent et aubin qui était venu nous
voir madagascar
l'hépatite us on va nous écrivait
souvent et nous donner des nouvelles de
titus son frère c'est le naturaliste que
je recherche
aubin donc quand je suis arrivée à paris
je me suis aussitôt rendu au domicile de
mon oncle et la personne il avait
disparu depuis dix mois sans donner
signe de vie ni même une adresse son
opus le joindre
avec ce extraordinaire bien sûr dans
votre métier c'est monnaie courante mais
pour une profanes comme moi c'est très
très surprenant volant club a travaillé
chez un entomologiste de bagneux
entomologiste un bon pas naturaliste
non il s'agit pas uniquement d'animaux
empaillés rassurez vous je crois qu'il
faut être en même temps un peu chimiste
un peu médecin enfin je me suis donc
rendu à l'endroit ont travaillé à
bagneux et la même chose disparition à
la même époque sans plus de trace ni
préavis d'ailleurs et quand j'ai dit que
j'étais sa nièce on m'a flanqué la porte
pour lui et je peux vous assurer qu'il
n'a jamais aucun démêlés avec la justice
on encore tam ont donc l'intention j'y
viens il est à la retraite il est dans
le loir et cher
c'est même un général en retraite j'ai
refusé d'aller le voir j'ai eu tort oui
c'est un set à vieillir c'est mon père
lui avait écrit souvent et il n'avait
jamais daigné nous répondre
mais il est vrai que si aubin nous
donner des nouvelles de titus c'est
qu'il avait vu quand vous avez raison je
vais aller dès demain dans le loir et
cher voir mon oncle et je m'y tiendrai
au courant
ah pardon l'extrait de naissance de bain
et une photo qui a trois ou quatre ans
comme il me l'avait demandé par le
bureau de la rue des sources
messieurs voisins venus en supplie oui
ne partez pas tout de suite vous avez
encore des questions à me poser en
quelque sorte oui oh je sais ce que vous
pensez alors cherchez la femme n'aurait
bien non non comme si on voulait dit mon
nom qui n'était pas marié fedou misogyne
alors je le vois très mal à 59 ans en
fouillant avec une danseuse faut quoi
s'enfuir lundi prochain à 10 heures du
matin
ah j'allais bien qu'il faudra qu'elle
respire un jour alors vous allez voir
votre oncle titus le général et vous
venez de rendre compte de votre visite
lundi prochain à 10 heures du matin
donc je crois jusque là c'est pas la
peine d'entamer des recherches si votre
anglais là bas là vous parlez pas
souvent dit donc mais comme vous le
faites c'est pas pour rien c'est un
inspecteur principal mathieu cette
réputation il y tient beaucoup
coquetterie elle a dit dans deezer
messieurs
[Musique]
tu es sûr qu'on n'a pas oublié lui poser
des questions
écoute alors je vais penser qu'on est
très fort
bon ben maintenant on va prendre le
petit train train quotidien et attendre
jusqu'à lundi
ça va être dur
[Musique]
la classe on y va oui mais avec tact et
discrétion a pas comme d'habitude
- il aime la visite
sur la cliente 1
[Musique]
non
brillant c'est ici mais si les
inspecteurs mais à connaître la maison
satan lui son cours du tournoi mais
qu'est ce qui lui était arrivé notre
pauvre d'ici paris by night
j'adore ça n'a pas l'air d'aller enfin
c'est quand même pas la visite à votre
oncle titus qui vous a mis dans un état
pareil
sa présence n'est pas la classique chez
les colonies c'est toujours le foie qui
est fragile alors racontez nous ça se
passait dans un petit salon n'a pas
demandé l'inspecteur avec et si tu étais
j'ai donc je vois là non ça va bien il
est non ça va mieux pour tout savoir
tout ça mais qu'est ce que j'ai comme
mal avec lui petit peu spéciaux vous
avez fait voir cette visite horrible
elle pour trouver d'abord non quitus
habite en pleine forêt donc surélevé au
château j'ai été reçue 0,6
on est inexact agressé par une sorte de
vieille chouette une espèce de
gouvernante qui m'a fait poireauter
pendant au moins une heure
oui mais où la vie qui vous étiez sous
maintenance toujours c'est curieux comme
tu frappes avaient tué mais ses débuts
alors au bout d'une heure c'est à dire
quand elle a vu que j'étais pas disposé
à bouger avant d'avoir pour aller au
général s'est fatiguée la première donc
vous avez parlé au général n'ont pas
c'est plutôt lui qui a parlé on s'est
parlé le mois d' inexact aboyer plus tôt
de quel droit ce que je forcé sa porte
une pièce qu'on n'a jamais vue est tout
sauf linéaire et enfin quand j'ai
prononcé le nom d'obama j'ai cru qu'il
allait avoir une attaque et plus jamais
voir le sinistre individu et encore
moins d'en entendre parler
le sinistre individu je résume
et croyez moi les épitaphes n'était pas
tendre il m'a fichu à la porte sans rien
vous dire de l'enclos ben oui je vais
maintenant c'est fait c'est parce que tu
y vas y sommes c'est moi qui l'a dans
l'attitude de votre ongle titus est
plutôt bizarre enfin même à votre égard
odieuse odieuse odieuse odieuse ce qui
ne prouve pas pour autant qu'ils aient
participé à la disparation de photo club
avec 10 à jhelum moi non plus mais
j'essaie d'imaginer
les hypothèses alors est ce que vous
comptez faire d'un on va entamer des
recherches votre convalescence va durer
combien de temps alors la télé alors que
non mais quand tu reviens du du banquet
de la mondaine est ce que tu sais
combien de temps va durer la tombe en
défense vous et moi vous connaît deux
mois maintenant je sais normal même aux
quatre jeunes
écoutez on est jeudi attendant que je
dise pas que vous laissez reposer
jusqu'à lundi un ça va puis lundi on
vous téléphone le lieu du rendez vous
d'accord je serai sur pieds d'accord
mais si je peux faire quelque chose pour
vous j'aimais tellement mon âge mais les
écouter certainement nous ferons appel à
paris c'est le talent y est c'est fini
on s'enfonce dans une région mais en
avançant pas mal on voit on s'en va
petit le plus léger
[Musique]
finalement ici c'est un peu comme à la
morgue
oui ça va ya plus de choix comme un oui
hein si c'est votre tisanes qui vous a
remis sur pied devriez me dire où je
puis m'en procurer on attend le parfait
se remarquent d'ailleurs le voilà qui
arrive tous et moi j'étais avec un
attaché du muséum un homme mais si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire que pêche pour
nous voiler ce judiciaire recherche dans
l'intérêt des familles m et la famille
si je me trompe est représentée par oh
excusez moi cette charmante personne je
la connais déjà joli but qui est à la
recherche de son oncle monsieur aubin
brillant elle est déjà venue nous voir
et d'y aller j'ai l'air comme ça mais
j'ai une excellente mémoire
si vous voyez ce que je veux rêver
affectivement moselle alcine briand est
venu demander à nos services alors comme
ça monsieur aubin bryant a quitté votre
laboratoire sans prévenir
ah oui et sans préavis trois étés semble
surprendre si on veut un brillant et un
des plus anciens et de mes meilleurs
collaborateurs et travaille au
laboratoire avec moi depuis plus de dix
ans si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
très bien élevé ça va très très bien
en même temps avec mois de septembre
c'est est un jeu lundi matin donc ce
matin à monsieur o'brien est parvenu à
son laboratoire ne pas été étonné outre
mesure
parce que je lui avais confié la
naturalisation
de magnifiques spécimens un pilliot père
en tue sans eux vous voyez ce que je
veux dire pas du tout imputer lmnp ce
que vous voulez dire
au bout d'une semaine je suis quand même
inquiété de l'absence de monsieur un
brillant où je voyais quelqu'un nouvelle
eh bien monsieur brillant la table chez
lui comment expliquez vous sa
disparition donc je ne l'espère pas tant
qu'acteur social des plus qu'un choix
donné ce n'était pas à moi de la donne
et si c'est à vous mais il n'y a pas ici
de personnes qui pourraient nous fournir
des renseignements sur le comportement
de monsieur ben rien enfin tu vas juste
avant son départ a pas de la peur une
personne ya visité sa secrétaire
particulière je veux dire très bien
d'après vous voulez que je ne cherche
pas à l'entrée vous n'avez pas essayé de
questions aux actrices y avons commandé
je ne sois jamais par une chose pareille
mesure
personnellement je n'y a plus en plus je
vais vous dire oui volontiers
excusez-moi z par mademoiselle précieux
alcine revient en france à la mort de
son père elle a deux angles oba
naturaliste qu'elle connaît et titus
général en retraite qu'elle n'a jamais
vu au domicile de bain elle apprend que
celui-ci ait disparu depuis un an
alcine saisi la police et les
inspecteurs mathieu était lié le conseil
avec beaucoup de difficultés d'aller se
renseigner auprès du général titus qui
exploite un domaine en province alcine
en revient malades
titus le frère de balla mise à la porte
l'employeur d'aubin confirme la date de
la disparition et appelle la secrétaire
particulière d'aubin
[Musique]
e
aimiez votre patron louis et vous
aimeriez savoir ce qu'il est devenu
oui ou non elle je vous en supplie de
nous marier
il avait promis à vous aussi mène à tout
même parce que sans ça jamais je
n'aurais vous n'auriez jamais quoi
mademoiselle très chiant mais bien aubin
avait 59 ans bien sûr mais dans son âge
il était très très très très comme
dirait le professeur si vous voyez ce
que je veux dire
comment quelques jeux qu'est ce que ça
veut dire à bientôt trois électriciens
monsieur aubin vous faisait bien ses
confidences pas tellement non vous
alliez bien chez lui non voulait pas
excusez moi mais vous le voyez bien en
dehors du laboratoire
oui tous les jours sauf le samedi et le
dimanche il a léché à faire en province
eh ben vous voyez que vous savez des
choses intéressantes comme ça il allait
chez son frère tous les samedis c'est ce
qui me disait il partait le vendredi
soirée de rentrée le lundi matin là
jamais tendance ou le lundi 15 septembre
où il n'a pas reparu depuis plus aucune
nouvelle
et comment allait-il chez son frère aux
voitures il avait une deux chevaux
il m'emmenait de temps en temps au bois
de boulogne je suis bien passe à son
garage mais ils la paient pas n'est pas
vous voyez hein vous en savez des choses
quand vous voulez dites moi mademoiselle
autrichien à part vous y at il quelqu'un
dans le laboratoire qui pourrait nous
donner des renseignements sur monsieur
aubin non je crois pas non il y avait
bien quatre filles à la manutention mais
c'était avant moi avant vous je veiller
au grain parce que sans ça au bac
la preuve je suis sa nièce mademoiselle
je me disais aussi vous n'êtes pas son
type vous n'avez plus besoin de moi et
bien voilà qui nous fait voir votre
oncle sous un nouveau jour
en tout cas nous avons appris une chose
importante à savoir que la dernière fois
que l'on a vu monsieur un brillant il se
rendait en week end chez son frère face
à ce qu'il a raconté aux électriciens y
avait peut-être une autre petite amie en
temps au baryton par ex et sa nuit est
en tout cas une visite au général
s'impose mais avant on va passer chez
votre oncle urbain quand même a conçu un
jeu non
[Musique]
on
comment
on va
à
[Musique]
ça s'est gentiment passé on allait en
tirer à moins de payer les factures en
souffrance et comme il n'ya pas de
budget prévu pour ce genre de choses n'a
pas j'ai quand même réussi à lui
soutirer le vrai car demain elle va y
faire un tour on sait jamais me
choisisse y annoncer papa tellement nous
pourquoi parce que pendant que notre
camarade à la barre est maintenant
accompagné sur la pratique et vous savez
cette mallette mais bien sûr le bain
alors rendez-vous bretagne et à banques
ou bureaux grand chose pour elle est
pourrie la vente couvreur a même pas les
frais avant et le propriétaire de tous à
votre avis qui est de quel type s'était
pas excusé moi je crois le topic c'était
vous oui la copie d'accords mars indique
toujours pas cette attitude qui était
dans la mouise mobilier se trompent
forte je peux fouillé là dedans
vous êtes la course ne m'enflamme signer
une décharge je veux faire perdre à face
qui tourne mal à la trouver
avant ça vous plaît tant le travail
brûler les meubles j'aime ça j'aime bien
aussi donner la tête de ceux qui vont
avec paty reviennent pour les chercher
je me dis cela c'est ce duo ou du 45
je me trompe rarement
un des lettres de femmes belles et et
qu'elle était de la santé quoi ticket le
pl3 bojana temps il devait en faire
collection offrir bon eh ben on va
pouvoir refermer tout ça j'ai beau
fouiller partout quelques unes voulait
avec ba ba leur trouvera il a disparu on
bat mettez-vous à sa place des meubles
ou si moche ça vous donne pas envie de
séché environnement fascinant si jamais
ils revenaient voir son mobilier mon
client
faites moi signe bako 1
[Musique]
ouh ouh
monsieur pierre suivi non mais oui moi
le café fait bien pmu ici oui mais c'est
fermé aujourd'hui une scène mais la
personne qui s'en occupe et par la
police c'est fernand c'est pourquoi
alors est ce que tu crois petit j'ai la
confiance pas propre
moi vous savez pour ce que j'en dis
dites moi je voulais savoir si vous êtes
dans votre clientèle du prévenu
l'un des siens certain monsieur brillant
aux un brillant ce truc là
les visages c'est bien pareil ça va ça
vient
c'est différent c'est un habitué une
paille qu'on n'a pas vu combien de temps
voilà environ 10 points il jouait
beaucoup et même une poignée pas souvent
fait vous dire
ça me fait de la peine merci
on
[Musique]
oh
tout ce qu'ils gagnaient passer aux
courses
oui mais ça nous explique par ni
pourquoi ni comment il a disparu
d'autant qu'un joueur ne changent pas
facilement ses habitués de terrain
supposons que tu sois un très vieux
coureur de jupons ce c'est une
supposition impensable et parfaitement
comme les autres mon petit bonhomme est
qu'à 59 ans pacte c'est pas croyable
quoi j'ai pourtant je crois avoir tout
vu à chaque fois ça pour ça un coup de
pot etc à 59 ans tu te déconne qu'une
petite minute de 25 ans est ce que tu
comptes il abandonne aussi facilement à
la conclusion est d'abord plaisir
monsieur robert briatte raison pour
disparaître peut-être même n'at-il pas
disparu de son plein gré en très bon
modèle a ses défauts alors m
dix nouveaux et vient hélas non c'est
invraisemblable chercher enfin mais
c'est ce que nous faisons demoiselle
mais à paris il semble que nous ayons
fait le tour de la question sans
résultat il reste non votre oncle titus
et bien quand portons-nous vers
donnez-moi moselle mais nous ce sera
tellier et moi pas vous mais mon truc ça
d'accord allait moins bien
notre visite chez votre oncle titus est
déjà une entreprise délicate
alors si votre simple présence risque de
le rendre furieux je comprends pourquoi
bien ensemble d'autant plus qu'il peut
être aviez refusé de nous recevoir
enfin vous êtes et la police un verre
mais justement pour aller chez les gens
plus que quiconque il faut qu'on nous
invite vous n'avez qu'une idée c'est
tout laisser tomber
vous voyez mal mademoiselle renommée
nous déplorons simplement la minceur de
nos indices votre oncle ho pin dit qu'il
se rendait chez son frère mais nous ne
sommes pas sûrs que ce soit cette fois
là de même que nous ne sommes pas très
sûr non plus que le témoin mills tricia
secrétaire particulière de votre pierron
n'est pas tout inventé avec eux pour se
rendre chez un monsieur que vous
décrivez vous même
aimable c'est mince ces conditions
puis j'espère doit être tenu au courant
mais certainement moselle merci
aïe charmant caractère il semble qu'elle
tienne sein de sa famille domaine de la
galerie c'est bien ça qui adorent ce
qu'un cent hector troisième prix de 10
départements bouaké le chat c'est tout
là c'est l'entrée principale et un
kilomètre d'ici vous tire une entrée
secondes
julia marquez qui a déjà fumé alors et
bats depuis que ma cheville est a sauté
sur une mine portant des cartes et puis
c'est tout allez on y va et fait
attention aux mines
à
j'ai l'impression que nous sommes
attendus
[Musique]
mon impression est basée sur des faits
précis
enfin couvre regarde en haut du
la fonctionnaire doit être la
gouvernance
je sais pas sa fiancée
et quel sujet bonjour madame inspecteurs
mathieu inspecteurs scellier police
judiciaire de paris direction de la
police judiciaire de paris
nous voudrions voir monsieur titus
brillant général bryant
c'est alors le général
drire du cadre de réserve si vous
préférez je peux faire pourquoi
voulez-vous voir le général mais ça on
lui dira nous mêmes rudolf c'est
agréable qui est ce monsieur garde
chasse
il est vraiment indispensable qu'il a un
fusil à la main nous avons été attaqués
l'année dernière nous sommes devenus
méfiants laverda quoi faire un mandat
d'une enquête officieuse pour le
procureur de la république en vertu de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
à moins que vous préfériez quand la
chercher les gendarmes jamais dit qu'on
voulait pas vous recevoir
vous avez seulement préciser les limites
légales de l'entretien vous désirez
revoir les vous me suivre le général est
à son bureau et limitent d'ailleurs même
plus gouvernement des cours de droit
alcine revient en france à la mort de
son père elle a deux oncles oba
naturaliste qu'elle connaît et titus
général en retraite qu'elle n'a jamais
vu chez le naturaliste ou travail aubin
les inspecteurs mathieu était lié à des
roches de secrétaire très particulière
qui leur apprend kubala quitter chaque
week-end pour se rendre chez son frère
le général au garde-meuble tellier
fouilles dans les meubles d'aubin et
découvre de lettres de femmes et de
nouveaux tickets de pmu mail enquête
piétine reste le général titus les
inspecteurs sont reçus par une étrange
gouvernante et des nombreux curieux
garde-chasse
[Musique]
ces messieurs sont de la police j'ai
vérifié leurs papiers
le polish marocaines ont leurs entrées
mission très je vous en prie vous serez
servis m'appelait à 6000 enfants alors
que puis-je bourg où tu es si vous
quittez pour les oeuvres de la police
désolé mais vous collègues de ronces ont
déjà passé votre nièce je crois est venu
vous rendre visite dernièrement pour
éboué et une personnes se prétendant ma
nièce a effectivement demandé à être
reçue si oui elle désirait savoir ce qui
était devenu son oncle aubin notre frère
disparu depuis dix mois mais pourquoi me
demander à moi et vous faire monsieur
qu'est ce qui vous laisse supposer que
je suis libre oui qu'est ce qui vous
laisse supposer que je que je suis en
mesure de vous répondre et votre frère
robin a dit partout autour de lui qu'il
venait passer chacun de ces week-ends
chez vous or c'est au cours de ce
week-end qu'il a disparu
vous avez envie des choses mon frère en
bas oui de lucie kempf en week-end c'est
vrai beaucoup trop bourré mais ça
n'avait rien de régulier
votre façon c'est pas la première fois
qu'il serait resté une année sans voir
là je me passait très bien de sa
présence
figurez-vous en tout cas je ne veux
solliciter jamais observé je n'ai pas le
paf et pique assiette et seulement il
était discret mais non mais non mais non
il donnait des conseils invité ses amis
courait après les filles de faire un
être insupportable et vous le supportiez
bas on nous avait de plus en plus
difficilement je lave ou lors du dernier
week-end qu'il a passés ici pour magna
jamais dernier week end
c'était le 15 septembre lors de ce
dernier week-end n'y a pas eu de rupture
définitive entre votre frère et où ça
croyez bien que si j'avais pu mais on a
été beaucoup trop bas ville pour ça on
réfute un temps nous entendions parfait
et puis le ch femmes le besoin perpétuel
d'argent et puis 7-7 manière religieuse
d'un mouvement de terrain mais enfin
tout de même en général le fait qu'il
ait disparu avec sa deux chevaux depuis
dix mois et que personne ne l'ait jamais
revu depuis ni lui ni sa voiture
ça ne se faisait pas non j'en ai vu des
gens dans ma vie disparaître les termes
des bagages
vous allez en 40 ans maman d'un débat
jeu des capitaines dans un régiment
d'artillerie lourde sur voie ferrée eh
bien mon limitée a perdu je dis bien
perdu un canon de 35 mètres de long et
pesant 150 tonnes
lui non plus n'a jamais retrouvé
vous pensez qu'il s'est suicidé
nous ne pensons pas en général nous
faisons une enquête
je vous demande pardon général mais
comme vous êtes satisfait de votre garde
chasse c'est pourquoi il ne doit pas
plaisanter avec les bras trop haut
croyez moi monsieur si vous aviez du
gibier sur vos terres ou si vous seriez
imperméable à l'humour des braconniers
ont mis sur votre mission est sa
réussite
après tout je ne désire pas la mort du
pêcheur retrouvé le temps qu'il vous
plaira men vous donnez pas la peine de
le ramener il trouva bien le chemin tout
seul
à votre santé bon maintenant messieurs
je vous demanderais de bien vouloir
m'excuser une série de rendez vous pour
gérer un domaine comme celui ci n'est
pas une petite affaire
nous n'en doutons pas superbe tableau en
général est très ressemblant oui je
remercie mon bon vieux messieurs voilà
au revoir et au plaisir des yeux
[Musique]
où l'arrivée ou sans le tenir en estime
je suis à 100 service depuis si
longtemps
que pensez-vous du frère à grand chose à
vrai dire je les à peine connue avant je
partais pour le week end du temps mais
avant quoi avoir la maladie du général
comment le général avec le mot no il
n'est pas encore guéri et au début
c'était encore pire c'est à peine s'ils
pouvaient pas qu'en pense le même sens
il a jamais voulu avoir un seul
et quand il s'est mis dans la tête
quelque chose au revoir monsieur vous
connaissez le chemin ne vous en écarter
pas le garde chasse bayeux au revoir
merci pour tout à bientôt
on n'est pas obligés de venir
attenton à droite j'ai vu qu'ils avaient
une ferme là sur le plan humain bien
aller jeter un oeil oui mais les noms et
le garde-chasse vote occupe whissell et
les champs de mines
il faut bien mourir de quelque chose à
l'hérésie en route
ça vous fait sortir de la voiture
je me suis police judiciaire de paris
qu'est ce qu'il vient faire ici la pj du
sud de paris mais elle voulait prendre
un raccourci qui s est perdu mais
vraiment un talent y est vous êtes d'un
compliqué c'est pas incroyable sur le
bandit suffisait de suivre le chemin en
arriver tranquillement je vous préviens
si la voiture à la moindre égratignure
que vous un rapport d'allier c'est à
dire monsieur le principal on me fait
beaucoup parler de monsieur je voulais
en profiter pour l'interroger
alors évidemment ça change tout là on le
dit bah oui c'est parfait mais c'est
trop tard dites moi vous connaissez
monsieur aubin frère du général prg y
pense bien que je reconnais devenu ici
pendant des années et quand l'avez-vous
vu pour la dernière fois monsieur aubin
ça veut dire exactement
non peut-être bien un peu moins un
batelier c'est pas votre jour de chance
un monsieur est incapable de nous
renseigner au nom c'est à dire moi pas
mais je peux vous envoyer quelqu'un
c'est vrai au ca serait gentil
oui il ya robert le cuisinier du château
à c'est un ami seulement pourra faire
attention pas vous faire prendre par
blanche neige oui c'est la gouvernante
du général ah bon mais merci à bientôt
pour partie à vous pouvez prendre par
cette route
seulement attention aussi vous louper le
tournoi
on vous retrouve le cul dans l'eau et a
beaucoup qui s'en servent non pro
tellement reconnaître ici on vend la
prenait souvent des bains bientôt un
attention vla robin des bois c'est
vraiment un garde chasse et la drôle de
manière
vous savez il ya pas seulement un an il
était encore braconniers pas ce qu'il
lui a pris au général donné un fusil un
piquet pareil là qu'est ce qui vous
prendre sept fous on est perdu en
cherche le chemin
vous n'avez alors foutez autant pas dit
dans vos fautes et le caousou team temps
tu es fou rudy c'est la pj mais giroud
page tirs d'armes
j'ai le droit je sais remontée jeu
[Musique]
qu'est ce que je fais lui fonce dessus
maintenant il fait ce qu'on lui dit cet
homme
voilà le militant
[Musique]
c'est pas malheureux de voir ça
suite
non mais t'as vu ça tu sais qu'ils
auraient été capables de tirer cet
imbécile faut le boucler en vitesse et
en tout cas ya des choses plus
importantes savoir si oui ou non aux
bains est venu voir son frère le
week-end du 13 au 14 septembre bâton
futurs copains là robert le cuistot
pourra peut-être l'on enseigne et nous
espérons le si je tombe nez à nez avec
le garde disant à propos du garde ta
rien remarqué quoi il est devenu
garde-chasse à peu près à la même époque
seuls à laquelle aubin a disparu doit
oui ça m'a fait un peu aussi basse une
coïncidence sais pas peut-être ou
peut-être pas en attendant on va s'en
débarrasser emmène moi la gendarmerie
une offert drip que oui c'est un
pensionnaire de la clinique
psychiatrique dr evra le général a
proposé de recueillir il y a trois ans
on faisait des corvées dans la propriété
un homme de main dingue non
un ancien d'un gain d'affilée il n'était
pas sous surveillance
6 il vient très régulièrement la
consultation mais il n'a jamais été
assermenté et encore moins de droite
pour qui la cuisine
nous allons régler ça tout de suite pour
le moment je deviens pour le moment je
préférerais que les choses se passent un
peu plus discrètement est ce que demain
on pour être tranquille de 15 heures à
18 heures et ont enfin d'autres termes
est-ce que vous pourriez leur vie
en calant en disant je sais pas occulter
gaston cabannes alors un vagin j'ai un
copain qui est douanier
c'est sûr que c'est un copain les
hausses à tuer pas bah c'est pas le réel
est atteint attention le vla l'eau ah
ben ali l'ami 12e est fière de ses
passes il faut que ça
[Musique]
alcine fuir chez son oncle aubin
naturaliste la secrétaire très
particulière de bain révèle que ce
dernier a disparu depuis près d'un an au
cours d'un week-end de passer chez
quitus général en retraite frères dubaï
la gouvernante du général n'est pas plus
rassurante que le garde-chasse titus
confirme la visite de son frère qu'il
tient en piètre estime où pendant qu'ils
interrogent le métayer les deux
inspecteurs sont surpris par le garde
qui les chassent et décide de revenir
après avoir éloigné l'inquiétant
personnage avec le concours de la
gendarmerie
[Musique]
elle
et
tintin bush père et bush père va
peut-être venir a tout oublié quelque
chose
ah bah j'ai une bonne influence sur toi
tu deviens prudent alors on commence par
quoi
le paysan d'abord savoir quand tu vas
chez baader et puis ensuite le chemin
que nous a barré le garde-chasse et est
ce que si on en interdit de circuler par
là c'est quelque chose
n'oublie pas que c'est le chemin
qu'emprunte est notre cher robin mais
c'est fini ce cigare tue c'est emballant
mais je suis de taille mais ça me fait
rire y attend
hu
[Musique]
pj risque pas de s'échapper dossier
bonjour je regarde vous a laissé passer
comme ça alors rencontrés sur la route
là il avait reçu une convocation de la
gendarmerie et l'histoire le papier
militaire alors avec l'administration ça
risque de durer un bout de temps surtout
qu'avec ce bout là il en connaît moins
important de les pièges en bois etc ou à
bosser pour de refus encore tu regardes
les bêtes
[Applaudissements]
et moi me faut vous gardez vous fait pas
peur des fois aussi plus tôt et robert
le cuisinier là vous avez pu avoir un
rendez vous appelez le bébert comme tout
le monde
oui vous attendre à la tombée de la nuit
dans la cuisine du château
rentré en petites portions de côté plus
dur c'est d'y arriver après on risque de
trop rien blanche neige et avec général
à l'autre bout et la nuit tomba gunners
cette saison
8h 8h30 vous entendez monsieur le
principal faudra pas oublier téléphoner
à la gendarmerie
mais avant d'aller faire un petit tour
sur le chemin d'aubin mabri s'assure
donc en riant
fou mais tu es fou un lunapark y en a
marre 1 bat bravo papa voilà bah tu as
gagné tu peux pas dire que t'as pas été
prévenu un look pas loin mais on n'est
pas bien pas encore non les bras
l'étendue de ta connerie ans non merci
ça se connaît et quoi encore là à quoi
ça la met bas salat salaces et une et
c'est une carcasse de ce compte
alors on va foncer chez le paysan qui
lui demandait qui viennent avec son
tracteur qui selon toi
j'aurais dû m'en douter oui tu contre
lui si la vision de marée est basse et
des martyrs à pied c'est touchant
et paul petit chéri samba tu vois quand
tu veux
[Musique]
bah
c'est pas du matériel amos 33 cd 75 et
c'est bien la voiture d'aubin alors elle
va jusqu'où les tendres udem économistes
ont pris un agent ça fait partie
panoplie du parti policiers ne faut pas
en abuser
nantes a vu la porte du côté du
conducteur ouverte oui le levier de
vitesses est en première mi-temps les
faits des dons faut toucher à rien c'est
important pour les experts vous en
faites prendre vu ça à la télé puis pour
le monde qui passe par ici dit dans
l'autre fois quand on a failli plonger
là oui ok en troisième si j'avais été en
première je me serais arrêté sans aucune
difficulté
quand même bizarre que sa bagnole soit
rester là dedans pendant dix mois sans
que personne s'en aperçoit je sais bien
qu'il fasse froid beaucoup de monde ici
mais quand même c'est qu'il a fait ce qu
il connaît forcément le niveau baisser
ou en tout cas on peut plus continuer à
travailler comme ça non moi je fonce à
paris pour rendre compte et effet andré
une information 1 et après un ou le
grand jeu et tu reviendras caen demain
dans la matinée faut que je croise
encore au parquet de rouen toi tu va
rendre visite à des données n'oubliez
pas de passer à la gendarmerie pour le
garde-chasse au monsieur le principal et
méprisant
[Musique]
tous
ça promet tram inspecteurs dehors vous
n'êtes pas fait repérer voilà
gouvernante faut que jamais les pieds
ici verront comme et les provinces et la
gueule dans les couloirs général
en général ça je crois bien qu'il ait
jamais mis les pieds ici dit ouais parce
que bien une décôte hab spécialité ça
c'est vraiment moi j'en connais un qui
soit 7 à moins bon dit pourquoi revenir
lorsqu'il nous intéresse alors au comme
habitant au château coujan il ya quoi
ils général de gouvernance et puis me
disent que c'est sous la bichonne jeunes
crient que général a fait engagé à
servir à table alors s'appelle général
la gouvernance b jours et puis le grand
fleuve et mon chien une chose qu'on
pardonne bursa ouest biche bien chercher
leur époque chez voulez moi pour de
maintenant d'habitude at elle dit
vous croyez pas que général rodolphe
rapetti pas pourquoi ils pas tellement
porté sur les femmes général dit voulez
vous demandez là monsieur aubin brillant
nous connaissent et saint gobain montre
des films à leur âge mais généralement
une production très long terme on l'a
pas vu avec vous pourriez pas vous dire
exactement fin avec un peu plus de
précisions bonnes notes tout dans mon
carnet abonderait parce que la
gouvernante et n'a qu'un rêve c'est de
me mettre dedans
ouais bah lui et pour nous tiendrons
fourier sa décharge et septembre
voilà la dernière fois que les services
étaient 14 septembre
[Musique]
mme hébert mais d'un grand homme alors
sinon t'es sûr que la dernière fois qu
un but ici c'était le 14 septembre
dernier assure mme sudre parce que tout
ce qui est maintenant choses du bronze
qu'est-ce qui sait qu'est ce qui s'est
passé
le dimanche après son départ alors là la
timone montre ou moi tout ce que pour
cuisine je note porte alors c'est par
exemple alors alors je peux te dire que
car je peux te dire que le général est
tombé malade et puis porter une tisane
procédé c'était comme une attaque et on
peut parler alors il resté couché noir
pendant wahou pendant près d'un mois
rester en b br pour te remercier dommage
quand même faire un tour à l'étang à
tous et à la chaîne iii est quelque
chose de ports des navires jettent tout
moyen coûte moins pour ce qui est ton
dîner la ses meilleurs qu'à la cantine
de la police
[Musique]
alcine fait rechercher son manque aubin
naturaliste les inspecteurs apprennent
de la bouche même de la secrétaire très
particulière kobin a disparu il ya près
d'un an lors d'un week-end chez son
frère le général en retraite titus la
gouvernante du général n'est pas plus
rassurante que le garde chasse titus
confirme la visite de son frère qu'il
tient en piètre estime presque par
hasard
les policiers découvrent la voiture
dubaï merger aux trois quarts dans un
étang pendant que mathieu fonce à la pj
tellier à l'insu du garde de la
gouvernante va interroger le cuisiner du
château grâce au livre le compte il peut
déterminer la date exacte de la
disparition de ben qui coïncide avec une
longue maladie du général qui s'est
enfermé seul dans le noir durant un mois
poursuivant sa visite nocturne tellier
surprend une jeune homme qui pénètre en
cachette dans la chambre du général
pourtant réputé pour son puritanisme
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que tu sens de ma
surprise abbas alors c'est la manière
des chérubins et poulet c'est ce qu'on
va chercher à savoir qui obèrent on l'a
retrouvé à notons que ce serait beau la
poignée à mayol qui seraient plantés
dans le chenal lagarde garni et la
prochaine sera pauvre
à quoi tu joues la basse et le garde il
voulait faire un carton défiez rudolf a
essayé de vous tirer dessus en tout cas
il m'a menacé le [ __ ] alors tant mieux
ça fera un excellent motif d'inculpation
vous fait transporter à deux choix votre
brigade et vous vous êtes un guéridon
d'ex effet rendez vous au château
tiens je te présente bébert il a des tas
de choses intéressantes à te raconter
bel air en gérance et weber jean les 6
10 ans tu as la commission rogatoire
bien sûr pas problème alors raconte
eh bien j'ai la preuve écrite que aubin
a quitté son frère le dimanche 15
septembre écrite et le général a été
malade pendant plusieurs semaines après
le départ de son frère ça aussi c'est
dans le livre de genève aig
j'aime ce truc extraordinaire devrait
quel cuisinier il apparaît que le
général ne déteste pas les jeune fille
de 18 ans avant ça aussi c'est écrit
dans votre bouquin de cuisine il faut
pas trop en demander sa grâce aux
proches condeissiat grâce à vous et bien
maintenant pouvoir attaquer le général
de plein front et en force l'autre
qu'est ce que ça signifie de quel droit
commission rogatoire signé par le juge
d'instruction générale vous permettait
mais faites comme chez vous accusation
de recel de cadavre ou contre x mon
général c'est un sens c'est depuis ce
manteau je vais appeler mon ami le
procureur général de rang ne vous donnez
pas sa peine je me suis permis de le
faire avant je sors de son bureau
nous comprenons nous bien il n'est pas
question de vous suspectez de quoi que
ce soit un an encore le général bryant
cinq citations nous blessure un soeur de
cada c'est bouffon et de quelques
cadavres savait-il bain sans doute celui
de votre frère dont on a retrouvé la
deux chevaux dans les temps vous avez
retrouvé la douche - de mon frère dans
l'état oui derrière la ferme est le
corps était de dos non alors c'est à dar
ce fameux canard à leur rythme on le
cherche mon général oui on le cherche
on fait descendre vivre comme chaque
fois quitté cette maison pour graal pays
si après tout oui ce probablement un
accident je m'excuse mon général c'est
que ces enquêtes sont des années
mais comment faire autrement ce tableau
était fait à quelle époque il ya cinq
ans
qu'est ce qui se passe encore on vient
d'appréhender votre garde-chasse très
rendez pourquoi n'ont rien de grave il
ya longtemps que cet homme est à votre
service
désolé je ne sais pas d'abord il n'est
pas garde-chasse et les gardiens staff
est différent et braconner sur les
terres j'ai pensé qu'il valait mieux
l'occupait mais pourquoi toutes ces
questions à à propos la deux chevaux de
votre frère avait la porte avant gauche
ouverte et le levier de vitesse était
engagée sur la première étonnant vous
boîte et mon général oui une blessure de
guerre dans le tiroir de la commode
allô bonjour mademoiselle c'est
l'inspecteur mathieu voilà nous avons
trouvé un portefeuille en croco et un
briquet en or est ce que vous savez oui
non non je ne me quitte pas oui bon je
vous remercie beaucoup oui oui très très
important bien vous ne bougez pas de
votre téléphone je vous rappelle yann
attendu six mois qui vous offre la
communication bien qu'attendue il a été
acheté il ya deux ans chez un
maroquinier de tananarive est venue de
l'indépendance mesure avancent toutes
parts moselle un signe brillant laquelle
l'a offert à son oncle oba brillant ce
briquet appartient également monsieur
aubin brillant voyait les initiales sont
sur le couvercle comment se fait-il
qu'on les trouvait ainsi que ce
portefeuille en votre possession
quand et où vous êtes vous procurer ces
objets puisse le trouver dans le mur du
général c'est toi mais il faut aussi
d'un mensonge gignac croit je suis sûr
monsieur brillant regardez moi bien vous
avez dit que ce tableau date est de 5 en
espagne
alors quel rapport vous n'êtes pas le
général titus mais son frère
oh bah je vais vous raconter ce qui
s'est passé le dimanche 15 septembre il
y a dix mois effectivement sorti avec la
deux chevaux mais vous n'avez pas été
bien loin
vous avez acheté la voiture dans les
temps et vous êtes rentré immédiatement
au château que s'était il passé entre
votre frère et vous
je l'ignoré encore tout ce que je sais
c'est que votre frère était mort et que
l'idée vous était venu de prendre sa
place sait-on jamais ce que réservent
les successions vous ressembliez un peu
général il avait une cicatrice sur la
joue une musique à trice assez évidente
il fallait donc que vous ayez la même
donc vous voulez être faite devant une
glace seulement malheureusement vous
vous êtes trompé de côté et le général à
la cicatrice sur la joue gauche
vous vous l'étiez fait sur la joue
droite j'imagine que vous avez dû vous
en apercevoir malheureusement il était
trop tard si votre nièce alcine ne
s'était pas obstiné à retrouver son
oncle chéri ce que vous avez pu la ire
celle là bas c'est vrai de kosmala tél
et après quand nous sommes arrivés il a
fallu que vous jouiez serre est très
très serré ce moment là il en fallut
commettre aucune erreur avant or le
général avait les yeux bleus
les autres sont marron puis les verres
fumés ne cache jamais complètement un
regard d'ailleurs vous avez enlevé vos
lunettes pour lire la commission
rogatoire
le général ne boitait pas vous aussi à
la suite d'un accident de circulation
et puis surtout votre goût bien
compréhensible pour les jeunes personnes
alors que le
général est peut-être à ces puritains
c'est faux archi faux
j'ai des preuves jeu brillant je viens
de vous énumérer les raisons qui m'ont
fait découvrir la vérité pour l'épreuve
ce sera beaucoup plus facile
il nous suffira de comparer les
empreintes digitales
[Musique]
donc l'aube a tué son frère pas
exactement votre oncle dj set et
cardiaques les morts dans les bras de
son frère robin aubert la soirée du
samedi 15 septembre et oui votre oncle
aubin savait que son frère
beaucoup plus facile il nous suffira de
comparer les empreintes digitales donc
l'aube a tué son frère pas exactement
votre oncle dj s'était cardiaque il est
mort dans les bras de son frère robin
dans la soirée du samedi 15 septembre et
oui votre oncle aubin savait que son
frère souhaitait léguer tous et bien une
maison de retraite
vous allez donc décidé de récupérer ce
qu'ils estimaient devoir lui revenir de
droit edd et de rudolf promu par la
suite au rang de garde chasse comme prix
de son silence
ils l'ont dépouillé de ses vêtements
laisser le briquet le portefeuille de
votre clan pas dans les poches au cas où
plus tard on découvrir un cadavre qui
pouvait pas prévoir c'est que rudolf se
les approprient en enterrant le cadavre
et oui votre oncle aubin a boy courage
d'aider rudolf dans cette tâche cette
histoire super d'ibm et de ses parents
me nombreux savoir toute façon robin
n'avait pas se substituer à son frère
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant je crois que je vais
retourner d'harmonie
la page est déjà là et nous balancer ce
que j ai confiance alors à vous car je
travaille
du nom
c'est face à un bo
enfin
il meurt
j'avais jamais
dire adieu
car et plus beau
adieu
ce sont ceux que
[Musique]
soit
je me
je vais
[Musique]